[Music]
it was 2015 we were three months into
our parenting journey and there we were
new baby in arms discussing a big topic
that would change our family life my
husband and I were talking about what it
would take to go from being an
english-speaking household if we
committed to becoming a spanish-speaking
one to give you a little bit of context
my husband and I share a similar
heritage background
we're both Mexican Nicaraguan American
but were different generations for me my
parents had been the immigrants to this
country I'd been born in San Francisco
and raised in a spanish-speaking home
but for my husband his grandparents had
been the immigrants to this country his
parents had been born had been born in
Los Angeles
and raised at a time when they were beat
in school if they were heard speaking a
language other than English in large
part the policy had its intended effect
my in-laws lost their Spanish and
eventually raised my husband in an
english-speaking household fast
forwarding back to our conversation that
day my husband said but I'm an adult
aren't I too old to learn another
language and what about all those things
about American culture the things that I
grew up with if we choose to speak
Spanish at home will I be able to share
those with my kids I reminded my husband
that a choice to speak Spanish at home
didn't mean that her kids wouldn't learn
English they would learn English and we
wanted them to as choosing to speak
Spanish at home was more about choosing
to value both languages for our kids and
not one over the other I reminded my
husband of all the times that he'd
shared with me how he'd regretted not
knowing Spanish how it meant he didn't
have the closest relationship with his
grandparents I asked my husband if we
tell our kids it's really important that
you learn multiple languages but we
didn't find use for bilingualism in our
own lives would they buy it but they
think we were hypocrites there are two
things that I could talk
today why Americans should be more
bilingual or how we become it now given
that we're in an academic setting I'm
gonna assume that many of you have
already heard about the benefits of
bilingualism how bilingualism has been
linked to improved learning outcomes
enhance cognitive abilities more
financial opportunity the development of
empathy and interpretive skills many of
you might know that bilingualism has
been linked to delays and manifestations
of aging like dementia and Alzheimer's
given that this is Stanford after all
some of you may even know that in 2016
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences released a report that said
that fluency in English is no longer
sufficient to meet the needs of America
in a shrinking world nor the needs of
individual citizens who will interact
with other peoples and cultures more
than at any other time in human history
the overwhelming recommendation of the
Commission was that Americans learn to
value language education the same way we
value education in math in English as a
persistent national need so instead of
talking about why America should become
more bilingual I want to devote the rest
of my time to talking about how how do
we go from our current state where 80%
of Americans are monolingual and start
inching towards becoming more of a
bilingual society I'm gonna suggest we
can take three immediate actions to move
us in that direction first businesses
need to recognize the incredible
opportunity in the space when my husband
and I decided to speak Spanish at home
we were shocked at how few resources we
had to support our decision things like
an alphabet puzzle
where the letter correspondent to the
word in Spanish or books that had a rich
depth of vocabulary we couldn't find
them we ended up having to write our own
books and create our own resources to
support our decision this is a huge
business opportunity we're one of
millions of American parents that are no
longer okay raising a monolingual
generation American parents are looking
for ways to fold language learning into
their family lives I am myself from
starting a business in this space
where we provide in-home support and
guidance for parents and a platform that
connects individuals with language
fluency to language learners in their
communities I'll never forget last
summer after one such community session
a mom coming up to me with tears in her
eyes she said Ana we've chosen to speak
Spanish at home but I've been worried
for years that my daughter would just
associate the language narrowly with us
with our family life that my daughter
wouldn't see its larger place in society
getting to come to this outdoor session
helps my daughter see its larger place
of belonging her words meant a lot to me
because that was the goal of what we
were doing American businesses have an
incredible opportunity to create space
for other languages to belong in our
society and culture my second
recommendation is that American adults
take up a practice of lifelong language
learning now I know what you're thinking
I'm just bad at languages most American
adults feel that way but the truth is
American language education is broken
languages shouldn't be learned in
classrooms through reading and writing
languages need to be lived languages
should be acquired through hearing and
speaking so it's not that you're bad at
languages you likely just haven't had a
fair shot at it
the second think thing I bet many of you
are thinking is what my husband said I'm
too old I'm an adult
don't studies show that if you don't
pick it up as a kid you have no chance
at it
the truth is that learning a language
early in life gives you the benefit of
speaking the language in native
proficiency which simply means you won't
have an accent but there's nothing wrong
with accents accents are beautiful
accents are our proof that it's never
too late to learn another language so
let's remove the stigma around accents
in the United States so that more
American adults are willing to engage in
language education
I learned Arabic as an adult and though
I can't tell you was easy I can tell you
it was incredibly enriching and
something that continues to that I
continue to be grateful for to this day
my third
recommendation is that American parents
or future parents make space in your
homes for family language at learning do
it together kids look at parents for
cues and one of the best pieces of
parenting advice I received is that your
kids will do what they see you do not
what you tell them to do make space in
your homes for language learning devote
an hour a week to speaking to one
another in that target language maybe
your kids in an immersion program bridge
that learning back home maybe your kids
in middle school
surpri and learning a new language
Surprise them with a phrase that your
pick that you're learning you are or can
be your kids safe space do language
learning together it'll make a really
meaningful impact for your kids and our
future generations is it possible for
the United States to become more
bilingual and is it worth the effort my
husband speaks really good Spanish today
and he has this renewed relationship
with his grandparents that's priceless
my son is turning five this month which
I can hardly believe and the other day
he ran up to me and said mommy mommy
let's sing the Arabic number song and he
kicked us off what had this meant that
let our ball humza set sabatham any
epistle
he loves that song and I love that
teaching it to him has led to the
steeper interest he wants to know how
other things are said in Arabic he's
fluent in English in Spanish he's
learning sign language in school and
perhaps most importantly he truly
believes he can learn any language it is
possible to raise a generation of
Americans that embraced bilingualism and
trust me
it's so so worth it thank you
[Applause]
you